[Musique]
je travaille pour le jobstruck qui est
un dispositif partageant entre trois
associations d'insertion professionnelle
sur les Yvelines et je suis donc
coordinatrice et pilote de ce projet
c'est l'espace d'entretien dans lequel
je peux recevoir les personnes l'idée
c'est une fois que j'ai rencontré qui
soit venues à moi c'est de faire un
petit diagnostic pour savoir quelle est
la problématiques quels sont les
problématiques rencontrées par les
personnes et si une structure de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
peut être une solution à ce moment là on
va creuser un petit peu plus pour savoir
les envies et les difficultés précises
rencontrées par la personne et mon rôle
c'est ensuite de la mettre en relation
avec le bon interlocuteur nos
associations elles travaillent avec des
clients que sont des collectivités des
particuliers ou des entreprises qui nous
permettent de mettre en situation de
travail rémunéré les personnes qu'on
accompagne
je suis la directrice de l'étincelle qui
est l'accueil de jour départemental pour
les femmes victimes de violence nous
avons été donc lauréat de de France
relance ce qui nous a permis d'acquérir
ce bureau mobile pour aller vers les
femmes victimes de violence qui ne nous
connaissent pas ou qui hésiteraient à
venir jusqu'à nous ce qui est important
pour nous c'est de communiquer pour dire
voilà nous sommes dans ce secteur et
n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir si la
personne si la dame pousse la porte
qu'est ce qui va se passer elle va
rencontrer un travailleur social qui est
spécifiquement formé aux violences
faites aux femmes la personne va la
recevoir va l'écouter et va l'orienter
selon ses besoins
le nomadapart il y a un camion
pédagogique qui a été aménagé en
appartement témoins de manière à
présenter tout ce qui va concerner les
économies d'eau et d'énergie dans le
logement donc ça a été organisé en
présentant sur sur ma gauche tout ce qui
va être consommation d'eau et ensuite on
continue dans le logement en étudiant
tout ce qui va concerner plutôt les
équipements donc machine à laver la
vaisselle le frigidaire on parle
également qualité de l'air dans le
logement avec la ventilation et une
maquette qu'on sort à côté du nomade
appart
en fait le Moby sport c'est quoi c'est
un gymnase itinérant qui se balade dans
les communes et les zones rurales
notamment et en fait le but c'est
d'apporter le sport dans ces zones là et
de le proposer à n'importe qui
aujourd'hui on intervient avec des
enfants jusqu'à des personnes en
situation de handicap en passant par les
adultes les seniors les ados voilà on
peut proposer plus de 70 sports
aujourd'hui dans ce camion et la
particularité de mobile sport c'est
qu'on est plutôt sur des sports
innovants donc en fait c'est des sports
qu'ils ont pas l'habitude de voir à la
télé de pratiquer à l'école ou en dehors
dans des sections sportives donc à bord
de ce camion on retrouve des chaises
pour faire des équipes on retrouve de
quoi délimiter les zones avec des plots
des cerceaux on a des buts aussi on a
pas mal de matos ici pour avec des
filets